as oportunidades guardam a chave do
desenvolvimento da humanidade
essa é uma idéia um pouco difícil de
assimilar num primeiro momento mas se
vocês pararem para pensar como você
chegaram até aqui como a vida de você
chegou até aqui
quais foram as pessoas e oportunidades
que fizeram com que a sua vida chegasse
no patamar em que ela se encontra hoje
são perguntas difíceis de responder isso
até porque boa parte das pessoas e dos
passos que fizeram com que a nossa vida
chegasse no ponto em que ela está hoje
tudo foi feito antes mesmo da gente
nasce pensando por essa ótica eu gosto
de dizer que a minha história não
começou em 92 que foi o único ace mas
ela começou na verdade por volta dos
anos 70
nessa foto essa que está com a mão em
cima da minha cabeça minha tia ela mora
no sul da bahia ea outra minha mãe
esse sou eu quando tinha mais ou menos
15 anos na área estilo anos 90 os anos
70 foram exatamente a época em que minha
mãe se muda da periferia de salvador
para vir morar no rio de janeiro
inicialmente ela vai morar na baixada
fluminense quando ela tinha mais ou
menos 18 anos vai trabalhar como
faxineira como lavadeira como passadeira
sempre com muito orgulho de poder fazer
desse trabalho o sustento dos filhos
dela eu posso dizer que a minha história
começa com a chegada da minha mãe no rio
de janeiro os dois motivos básicos
o primeiro deles é que ao se mover para
o rio de janeiro a minha mãe aumentou a
gama de oportunidades que não só ela
teria mas também que eu e meus irmãos
teriam um outro motivo é que talvez
tenha sido essa transição sendo feita
através de muita dificuldade muita
superação tem um feito da minha mãe a
mulher que ela realmente foi pra mim uma
heroína uma guerreira uma mulher que
inspirou todos que estavam ao seu redor
este ano completa 17 anos que minha mãe
se foi é claro que pra mim e dos meus
irmãos
o que ficou foram valores missões
a gente vai levar para o resto da vida
a minha mãe mesmo não tendo tido a
oportunidade de acessar muito do ensino
formal valorizou demais a minha educação
e hoje olhando para trás eu percebo que
ela trabalhou a minha auto estima de uma
forma que quando era pequeno podia nem
imagina
lembro muito bem que é assim que eu
acordava a primeira coisa que eu tinha
que fazer é lavar o rosto escovar os
dentes após tomar café direto sem fazer
isso eu tinha que levantar no banheiro
lavar o rosto escovar os dentes
lembro muito da minha mãe falando que se
tivesse uma festa alguma comemoração eu
tinha que mexer melhor camisa que eu
tinha
se eu não fizesse isso eu ia ter que
voltar no quarto e trocar de roupa
a minha mãe nunca foi muito de olhar as
minhas notas mas no final do méxico
tinha que mostrar resultado
lembro muito da minha mãe falou uma
frase que simplifica muito na minha
cabeça
você precisa ser um preto sim senhor não
preto ghóez e eu não tinha noção naquela
época mas a verdade é que minha mãe
estava me preparando para viver no
brasil em que ser negro morador do
subúrbio que garantem muito mais uma
chance de estar entre os números da
violência porque entre os números do
progresso do país um país enquanto 75
por cento dos jovens que morrem de
homicídios são negros
o assunto que continua sendo comentado
nas esquinas é o time que ganhou na
semana passada uma pessoa que vai ser
eliminada do reality show
um país em que as pessoas clamam que não
existe racismo mas quando você assiste à
televisão o que você vê é sempre o negro
principalmente a mulher negra associado
ao sexo associado à pobreza associado à
subserviência uma das memórias mais
claras que eu tenho da minha mãe algo um
pouco antes de ela partir foi entregando
um jornal
esse jornal trazia a matéria sobre um
programa ela achava que tinha muito a
ver comigo
esse programa o programa jovens
embaixadores
esse é um programa que é desenvolvido
pelo departamento de estado americano
aqui no brasil em alguns outros países
eles pegam os jovens brasileiros de
grande potencial e levam eles para viver
em um intercâmbio cultural nos estados
unidos por três semanas
esse programa tem uma série de
pré-requisitos esses jovens precisam ser
estudantes de escola pública
os jovens precisam ter um bom desempenho
acadêmico esses jovens precisam falar
inglês
esses jovens precisam fazer trabalho
voluntário em suas comunidades
é óbvio que quando eu olhei pra esses
pré-requisitos eu falei não vou ter
chance já prendia todos esses pré
requisitos mas eram milhares de jovens
tentando sair com minha mãe entregou
esse folheto é ver muita fé foi
encontrando esse folheto depois que
minha mãe já tinha partido que entende
que aquilo talvez fosse um último pedido
dela resolvi me inscrever
algumas semanas depois eu descobri que
havia sido selecionado era um dos 35
jovens e um dos estados unidos
participar do programa jovens
embaixadores
não tinha noção naquele momento mas esse
seria um real divisor de águas na minha
vida eu voltei nos estados unidos certo
que eu queria entender mais quais eram
os mecanismos que levaram o brasil a
sair da forma que ele achar que eu
resolvi estudar economia
eu cheguei com o nome numa diz numa das
instituições mais elitista do país com
uma bolsa onde fazem uma reflexão eu
percebo que em boa parte das aulas para
assistir era provavelmente o único negro
na sala de aula mas na época isso
representava uma grande coisa para mim
porque a minha mãe trabalhou em
autoestima de uma forma incrível quando
entrava na sala e contava quantos negros
estavam aí eu tive essa sorte de que
minha mãe trabalhava a minha autoestima
dessa forma o programa jovens
embaixadores abriu mão de uma série de
portas para mim eu tive a chance de
voltar para os estados unidos estudar
inglês faz um curso intensivo de inglês
na califórnia diz parte da minha
faculdade nos estados unidos é claro
todas essas oportunidades eram
oportunidades que minha família não
teria condições de marcar mas mais uma
vez isso não representa um obstáculo
para mim eu enxergava que o único
obstáculo para alcançar os meus
objetivos era eu mesmo
é claro que sempre ficava aquela
pergunta
poxa jeovânio você é um cara diferente
você é um cara que se destaca você é um
cara que é um ponto fora da curva não
conseguia muito acreditar nessa história
eu não conseguia acreditar que eu era o
único jovem que vinha do lugar de onde
eu vinha que tinha história
poderia ter alcançado as coisas que
alcancei o que eu fui percebendo aos
tempos é que na verdade essa história de
ponto fora da curva talvez nem existe
uma curva talvez o que existe são
verdades insistem marginalizar no lugar
de incluir são verdades que insistem em
rotular
antes mesmo de conhecer são verdades que
a gente mais chega engole diariamente
justificam boa parte das desigualdades
na ideia de mérito cras ia quando na
verdade que não pode nem começar a falar
em mérito real se as condições iniciais
do jogo não são as mesmas
foi muito com esta vontade de querer
fazer mais pelo meu país que eu
participei de uma conferência que é o
programa global changemakers eu fui um
dos 60 jovens selecionados para irem
para londres se reunirem lá pra
aprenderem como botar um projeto social
em prática
eu voltei pro brasil certo certo de que
os jovens com grande potencial já
existiu
as oportunidades também já existiam e
que o meu papel era conectar esses dois
foi aí que eu desenvolvi o mda o mda
líderes do amanhã é um projeto que é
basicamente um treinamento de liderança
para jovens do ensino médio de escolas
públicas
esse jovem passa 13 treinamento que tem
duas vertentes principais a primeira
delas é fazer com que eles desenvolvam
um perfil de liderança dele
eles passam por uma série de atividades
a gente debate uma série de temas que
são extremamente importante para a
juventude brasileiro e espaço também
para um treinamento que tem uma
metodologia baseada nos sete hábitos de
jovens altamente eficaz
a outra vertente do projeto é fazer com
que esses jovens consigam colocar em
prática tudo que eles aprenderam
então eles desenvolvem o que a gente
chama de projeto já são comunitários pax
esses pactos nada mais são do que as
chances desses jovens desses jovens
resolverem os problemas que viveu em
suas comunidades dentro de si
max a gente sempre por exemplo vamos
falar de drogas que era um projeto em
que esses jovens vão para escolas e
promover um debate sobre os riscos do
uso das drogas
a gente teve também um multirraciais
multirraciais é um projeto que levava a
questão racial para dentro da sala de
aula estimular os jovens a pensarem
sobre isso discutirem esses temas e uma
das campanhas mais legais que fizeram
era chamado abraços grátis contra o
racismo e região para o centro do rio
se encontravam com as pessoas que
estavam passando a lhe ofereciam abraços
grátis e tentavam concientizar ela sobre
a questão da raça no brasil
é claro que o ideal é passar uma série
de missões pra gente eu percebi quem
conseguia quebrar dois grandes
paradigmas da sociedade brasileira
um dos primeiros paradigmas carregar
quebrava a ideia de que projetos sérios
e comprometidos não podiam ser
realizados por jovens
é parece que os tomadores de decisão do
nosso país esqueceram que um dia eles
também foram jovens
esqueceram que muito do futuro que a
gente vai querer deprecie país depende
do que é devotado hoje a juventude
brasileira
o outro paradigma que vai ligar a quebra
é a idéia de que as mudanças têm que vir
de cima para baixo
algum político vai chegar na minha
comunidade vai resolver alguma
organização vai entrar na minha
comunidade vai encontrar uma solução
para isso
não nós podemos fazer alguma coisa
como já dizia um show lá no século 18
última instância a soberania é do povo
os políticos estão no lugar que ele
também estão não pra esse lugar que
estão para atender às demandas do povo e
não o contrário
por isso é o nosso dever fiscalizar
modificar e adaptar e garantir que nosso
dever de cidadania não seja feito apenas
de dois em dois anos nas urnas foi por
histórias como a da kleiza que
participou da i d em 2013 representou o
projeto uma conferência internacional em
manaus e hoje cursa ciências sociais na
federal do rio de janeiro ou histórias
como a da ml que passou participou do
projeto quando ela tinha apenas 14 anos
e acabou de voltar dos estados unidos
como jovem embaixadora que eu acredito
que o futuro do nosso país caminha do
nosso lado os futuros governantes
futuro se os das grandes empresas o
futuro presidente pode estar do seu lado
agora a gente só precisa mostrar para
esses jovens o potencial que eles têm de
desencadear a mudança é com essa com
toda essa gama de experiências em mente
que eu fui percebendo que tinha 13
missões extremamente importante nesses
meus curtos 23 anos de vida
eu queria muito compartilhar suas
missões com vocês e que vocês levar
essas missões à frente
a primeira delas é que oportunidades
geram oportunidade desde jovem que perde
a chance de estudar medicina com uma
bolsa na universidade e no futuro vai
garantir uma chance de vida nova para os
seus pacientes até vocês que têm a
chance de ver hoje na internets absorver
uma série de idéias extremamente
valiosas e poderem compartilhar suas
idéias com seus amigos
nós somos seres humanos nós vivemos em
sociedade
enchida e recebe oportunidade a todo
momento
são essas oportunidades que nos unem são
essas oportunidades que nos
potencializam como seres humanos
e são essas oportunidades que garantem
que a evolução não seja um mero processo
natural mas sim constante
desenvolvimento diário e colega do que
nós somos hoje o que nós podemos ser
amanhã
não desperdicem as oportunidades quando
vocês abrirem mão de uma oportunidade
por acreditarem que não são capazes na
verdade estão dando dois passos para
trás o primeiro passo de vocês vocês não
subiram um degrau na escada de alto
desenvolvimento
o segundo passo é das pessoas que não
vão poder usufruir a oportunidade porque
você não a criou
por isso acredite em você diz a fci
essas oportunidades são o que realmente
nos dá uma chance de causar e criar
realidade não existem ainda e certifique
se de que nesse processo você está
levando outras pessoas junto com vocês
porque na verdade é isso que vai
garantir um mundo melhor não só para
você mas que os seus filhos dos seus
netos e para todas as gerações futuras
ea última coisa que eu queria que vocês
levassem daqui é que vocês não podem não
podem deixar de gerar oportunidade é
muito comum e muito confortável a gente
boa parte dos problemas do nosso redor e
acreditar que eles não são problemas nós
é como aquele bichinho que você joga na
rua que quando combinado com várias
outras pessoas que tomam a mesma atitude
já eram as enchentes que a gente vê nas
cidades hoje talvez com aquele menor que
mora na rua que faz parte de uma mesma
engrenagem social que você faz parte que
aparentemente não é um problema seu mas
por fazer parte dessa engrenagem social
representa um problema que vai retornar
pra você em algum momento se vocês
querem saber o que vocês podem fazer
para modificar coisas hoje com se saírem
daqui do telex
eu diria que eles podem conversar vocês
podem debater esses temas com seus
amigos e com seus familiares
não adianta fechar os olhos do trecho
está vindo na nossa direção a gente tem
que encontrar soluções
a gente tem que desenvolver essas
soluções uma das frases que fazem parte
de todos os momentos da guerra e que
todas as pessoas que participam do
projeto conhecem ela diz o seguinte
nunca do vídeo um pequeno grupo de
pessoas conscientes e engajados tem o
poder para mudar o mundo
de fato é a única coisa que têm o futuro
ta nas nossas mãos seja ele bom ou ruim
por isso que oportunidade e trouxeram
até aqui que pessoas chegaram essas
oportunidades e que oportunidades você
estão gerando hoje obrigado